speaking of non-entities let's move to
the final segment because Joe Biden
knowing that things are not looking good
he gave a speech a couple days ago to
just try to scare the high hell out of
everybody who should we fear most well
of course it's those extremist Maga
Republicans
yet now extreme maggot Republicans aim
to question not only the legitimacy of
past elections
but elections being held now
and into the future
the extreme Maga element of the
Republican party which is a minority
that party as I said earlier
but it's his driving force
is trying to succeed where they failed
in 2020
to suppress the right of Voters
and subvert the electoral system itself
malice you know we've got early voting
all over the country I haven't seen any
video of anyone being suppressed black
people not having IDs and being turned
around I did see a couple videos this
week of Hillary once again claiming that
Republicans were going to steal the
election although she called Trump an
illegitimate president and Stacey Abrams
uh while they're having record early
voting turnout in Georgia claiming that
voters are being suppressed there I'm
starting to think these people are
disingenuous well it's it's kind of
funny because in terms of campaign
issues vote for democracy seems to be a
slogan that is not really going to Rally
turn out and turnout is of course as
everyone knows what drives elections
it's not really the will of the voters
but frankly if if the argument is as
Biden said earlier that voting for a
republican is voting against democracy
that's the best argument for
republicanism I've heard democracy is an
obscenity and the idea that my neighbor
should have a say over my life is just
absolutely insane and I think we're
going to be seeing that I don't think
they're they're crying wolf I think
we're going to be seeing in the next 10
15 years
republican-led states that are going to
be tightening restrictions on ballot
access and I think that's a good thing
because there's far too many people who
have a say about things that they have
no idea about and shouldn't be running
their mouths about and I say this
ironically and not ironically and well
okay so here's another clip from that
very same thing it's a perfect segue
thank you uh malice Biden's already
warning us that there might be election
Shenanigans just in two days from now we
know that more and more ballots are cast
in early voting or by mail in America
we know
that many states don't start counting
those ballots so after the polls close
on November 8th
that means in some cases we won't know
the winner of the election
for a few days until after a few days
after the election
it takes time to count all legitimate
ballots
an illegal and orderly manner
Ron it seems pretty freaking obvious am
I am I cynical or what I mean is he
basically just saying hey you know a
pipe is going to burst somewhere in
Philadelphia on Election night and uh
you know what can we do about it okay so
let me tell you one thing about
Philadelphia you don't need a pipe to
burst to cheating Philadelphia
cheating in Philadelphia is open and
notorious it's been going on for decades
Republicans have done nothing about it
whatsoever
pipe bursts are in other places but uh
you know my understanding is that um you
know I can't reveal too much but I can
tell you the GOP has sent out Crack
teams of plumbers
to key precincts where there will be
repairs available 24 7. so not this time
not this time Satan I mean Viva this
this concept though that you know
they're prepping people to just not
expect election results on Election
night it's gotten worse and worse over
the last couple years but now they're
just outright telling you hey we just
got to figure out enough time to get the
results we want I I I'm young I'm only
42. when in the history of of modern
politics have we gotten used to the idea
that you do not know the results as a
rule on Election Day itself it's
occasionally happened when there was
litigation I remember back in 2000 but
now it's become the rule that you have
your elections and then it takes you a
few days sometimes a week to count the
ballots this is this is a Devolution of
Technology not an evolution I don't know
if that's the right word but we're
regressing this is not progress